welcome to the Health and Wellness
Center with Dr Joel Wallach and
pharmacist Keith Abel they believe when
it comes to nutrition and
supplementation the modern medical
system has failed you that our body is
divinely designed to repair itself given
the correct Foundation of nutrients with
a combined 85 years experience in Health
Nutrition and supplementation they bring
a unique perspective on how to manage
disease and improve one's health over
the next hour Dr Wallach and pharmacist
Keith will discuss health and wellness
topics seen in the news they'll discuss
Trends in nutrition and supplementation
and how you can take control of your own
health and your future let's get on with
the show
all the food and dietary supplements
that we mentioned on this program are
intended to contribute to the daily diet
and overall health you know they're not
intended for the use in the prevention
treatment mitigation or cure of a
disease or health-related condition uh
individuals who have or suspect that
they have an illness or who wish to
commence a diet or exercise program
should be Consulting with an appropriate
licensed health care practitioner for
their medical health history evaluation
diagnosis treatment and health
recommendations
so we got this program recorded and
we're going to be back now every week at
this time it's a new time I have uh
changed jobs as you know I am with
practicing pharmacist I've been a
pharmacist now since 1995. uh since 2012
I've been in long-term care practice uh
working with nursing homes and folks
that are in the uh
you know patients that are in the
nursing homes uh recently had to uh
because the company that I worked for
was owned by CVS they decided to cut
Staffing I was among those across the
country who lost the jobs in the
stamping cut and have returns to
Community Pharmacy and Dr Wallach I'll
tell you what it has been an eye-opener
being back in Community Pharmacy now
I've worked uh
I've worked in probably 15 different
locations now all the way to the
mountains of Eastern Kentucky and uh
just one of the things I've noticed is
since I've been away from Community
practices people have gotten a lot
sicker Dr Watt I'm now seeing uh you
know it used to be that you would see
you know senior citizens that have
multiple drugs that they're on uh you
know for treating all the different
metabolic syndrome conditions and and
everything else now I'm seeing folks in
their 30s that are on multiple
prescription drugs treating conditions
that we used to not get until uh you
know we were in our 60s I'm seeing
people that uh that are younger now that
have arthritis and and diabetes and and
heart disease and they're just on all
these medications and it's it's
something that concerns me Dr Wallach
and that's one of the reasons why I
wanted to get back on here and start
doing this again and I think we need to
go all the way back to the basics of
what's going on here and I'm going to
let Dr White expand on it but that's
right and I both believe that our bodies
were divinely designed that if you give
them all the nutrients that they need
the body knows what to do to repair
itself and to prevent disease and I
think this is what's at the root cause
of everything we're seeing now I mean
it's in the news constantly about all
the different diseases there's all these
different drugs being advertised on on
TV and and the radio now and they all
have these massive side effect profiles
that they warn you about with the real
fast talking lawyers in the uh
commercials and it's because our bodies
are not suffering from a deficiency of
pharmaceuticals our bodies are actually
suffering from a deficiency of nutrition
and that's what attracted me to Dr like
a long time ago somebody stuck this
little cassette tape in my backpack when
I was in my last year pharmacy school
they didn't put their name on it or
anything which was a big mistake on
their part because they had they had
their name and phone number on there I
was contacted them immediately after
watching after listening to this but
this crazy doctor that was on this
cassette was saying things completely
different from what my professors were
saying in school is some of the things
he was saying on there were questions I
had asked my professors during pharmacy
school like you know we were studying
about the blood pressure medication and
my question is
to the professor is why aren't we
teaching people how not to have high
blood pressure why aren't we teaching
them what they need to be doing diet
wise and supplement wise not to have the
high blood pressure and their answer was
because folks don't want to know all
they want to know is take a pill to
solve a problem and that has now
escalated to the point where people are
spending hundreds of dollars on
prescription drugs every single month so
Dr White I'm gonna let you take it away
okay well thank you foreign correct
um
um I'm going to go back to
uh three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 on Pearl Street in
New York City and the bluff we're
looking at construction of the Brooklyn
Bridge
Thomas Edison pulled the switch in the
first commercial electric generating
plant and within 18 years by 1900 there
was a world catastrophe
because prior to three o'clock in the
afternoon Monday September 4th 1882 wood
and Cole had been the fuel for cooking
and Heating
um going back thousands and thousands
and thousands of years
and the byproduct of using wooden and
coal for for fuel
were ashes these wood ashes and coal
ashes were 98 minerals and two or three
percent carbon and people would put
these ashes the wood ashes the coal
ashes into their Gardens and the
vegetables would suck up the minerals
and people would eat those vegetables
and get their minerals people would put
these uh wood ashes and coal ashes into
their food as a spice they're getting
minerals that way all by uh 1900 most
everybody had an electric stove they had
electric heaters and they had electric
bulbs and all this kind of stuff and
very few people had coal you know they
didn't even have fireplaces in their
house anymore to burn wood
and so this is a problem by 1936 the U.S
Senate came out with a document U.S had
a document 264 and they said that
that um the U.S Farm soil no longer has
sufficient Metals in it to support human
life because 1936 U.S Senate document
264. it was very clear what the problem
is and of course in animal industry
since we don't have health insurance to
pay for high cost of treatments and
prescriptions that kind of stuff the
farmers learned through the Departments
of Agriculture at the universities how
to prevent reverse diseases
and so
um I started looking uh at this sort of
stuff and make a long story short
I
um let's see here uh I was working uh
with Marlon Perkins the old Mutual
mahalwa Kingdom show and when I
graduated veterinary school he sent me
to South Africa to work on the White
Rhino conservation project I was able to
work on that and and actually catch 200
out of the 350 that were left in South
Africa and my first
um uh paper my first book was Rhino
Express and described that thing and of
course just before I went to go to South
Africa I was working my way through
veterinary school and I was working in
the Pathology Department it was
Christmas
1963 all the professors were off uh for
holiday I was there as a student and
um this farmer comes and he drops off 50
dead Lambs with me the night before he
had 500 beautiful Lambs six months old
two and a half three inches of wool and
they're ready to go to market after the
Christmas holidays and um he went to
feed him that morning
and they're all dead they all died at
night and the temperature had dropped
from 40 or 45 degrees which is not
unusual for mid-December uh in in
um Missouri
um
and all the Sheep died of hypothermia I
wrote up the paper got it published in
Veterinary journals it was my first
scientific publication well I was in
Africa working on the conservation
project Perkins took that paper and got
a 25 million dollar Grant was Barry
commoner from the from the University of
Missouri a department of biology they
called me back from Africa and of course
I had caught 200 white rhinos in back
then it was only 350 left now there's 21
000 so I'm very proud of that
and to make those very sharp the grand
take out with my paper on the 500 dime
from hypothermia it was 25 million
dollars and I was supposed to find a
species of animals in the zoos that
would use as the equivalent of the
um old coal miners using canaries in the
mind okay when the gases would get in
the mind the canary drop off the perch
and die and the coal miners do to get
out to save their lives well the idea
was to use
um because of these these sheep dying
from hypothermia because they were
getting
contaminated with nitrate fertilizer
from all the surrounding farms and when
the temperature dropped their thyroids
were dead after six months of being on
this high nitrate drinking water their
thyroids were dead and they couldn't
maintain their body temperature died of
hypothermia got it published and very
excited about that
we'll make a long story short it turns
out that um you have sent a document 264
as I said 1936 tells a story this just
keeps getting worse and worse and worse
and worse and so when it became uh a
Nature Valley doctor okay I had already
found uh the cause prevention and cure
of cystic fibrosis supposed to be the
iconic genetic birth defect in humans
and I found it in a baby monkey who was
supposed to go to space for NASA and I
got permission to do biopsies in the
other 24 baby monkeys in the facility
Yorkies primate Center at Emory
University in Atlanta Georgia and they
all had cigarbrosis so I knew they
weren't related to each other other than
they were monkeys they didn't have the
same moms or dads or grandmoms or
grandparents or anything like that and
so it had to be an environmental thing I
traced it back to a deficiency of a
single mineral and to make a long story
short
um
and some years later I was working with
our attorney Jonathan e-mort and we beat
the FDA nine times in federal court and
got these minerals put into baby
formulas to make a long story short
within 90 days after we got to put in
the baby formulas we were able to get
rid of cystic fibrosis the birth defect
we're able to get rid of muscular
history thought to be a genetic Disease
by medical doctors and then
um gave it to um let's see here uh gave
it to Jerry Lewis and he was excited
about it they fired Jerry Lewis and shut
down the Telethon and then we were able
to get rid of cinnamon death syndrome
Sid supposed to be the mothers laying on
the babies and suffocating them so you
don't hear about those three diseases
anymore
okay City fibrosis
and cinnamon death syndrome says they're
all gone because we've forced them to
put this nutrient into baby farmers and
it worked very very proud of that now
the same thing is true for the rest of
us we have all these diseases that are
caused by nutritional deficiencies and
because we don't have access to these
nutrients anymore the wood ashes are
gone the coal ashes are gone and and
doctors say oh just eat well you get
everything you need you don't need to
take vitamins and millions you just
wasting your money just eat regulars you
need that's absolutely a lie and so at
that time I started
um writing up articles and so forth and
I was getting obituaries from medical
journals like any obituaries from
medical journals or medical doctors and
they're dying at 35 while they're
running a marathon they died 35 of a
heart attack
okay and that kind of stuff
and so I started getting these
obituaries of these doctors dying of all
these different diseases that they're
saying are genetic
and these doctors are dying by the
hundreds every year in America and so I
was getting their obituaries from the
medical journals and I'm handing copies
of these obituaries out to people in big
meetings of a nutritional companies are
people like um
various
organizations that supported people's
wanting to use vitamins and minerals
okay and so
um it was very very interesting and so
one of these places I was handing out
these obituaries and this guy was very
which they say he was very irate and he
was a doctor he says what are you doing
handing out obituaries at doctors at
meetings like this this is this is awful
you can't do that I said well because
Dead Doctors Don't Lie and that turned
out to be my first best-selling book
this is the
hard copy okay that was the original
printing a hard copy and of course it's
in nine languages in CDs very very proud
of that and so
it goes into many of the diseases the
doctors had
uh a hundred and 120 degrees wrong 120
degrees wrong okay
um they were missing it by A Thousand
Miles they were saying oh this is
genetic okay like high blood pressure
nope simple nutritional efficiency
diabetes genetic no simple nutritional
deficiency uh heart attacks hypertrophy
cardiomaptic heart disease uh 500 to a
thousand young athletes die every year
okay these are I mean these are high-end
athletes okay and they die the 25 of
between 18 and 25
from hypertrophy cardiometric heart
disease a deficiency of a single mineral
and so that's why I was handing out the
obituaries of doctors okay and of course
I'm a physician myself but I've been
taking the 90th Century nutrients since
I was nine years old because I did have
Tourette's Syndrome it turns out I
believe my Tourette Syndrome was caused
by the consumption of two things one was
you know we I grew up on a farm a beef
Farm we had Gardens and
um we were
um
uh you know fertilizing was the standard
fertilizer in our Gardens at that point
and are you hearing me pharmacist Keith
versus Keith oh
are we on the air
hello hello
we hear you Dr Wallace okay okay thank
you yeah there's something on the screen
there and I I didn't believe I was still
on okay okay so anyway it's one of those
things where
um
the population has to take these
vitamins and minerals to make up the
deficit okay and including
um you got to get rid of the bad foods
to stop absorption wheat boileran oats
wheat run oats have gluten in them and
they destroy your intestines and you get
things like um oh irritable bowel
syndrome Crohn's disease celiac disease
diverticulitis metabolic syndrome
Central Nervous System demyelinization
25 of your brain weight is cholesterol
25 of your spinal cord weight is
cholesterol and doctors once you get off
of cholesterol because they mistakenly
believe the cholesterol plugs your
arteries you know it's fried foods and
cooking oils okay then there's
Parkinson's disease Alzheimer's disease
um then there's let's see here Ms
multiple sclerosis gambarre syndrome
those kind of things these are all due
to the white matter of the brain going
away okay the the
demyelization and it's caused by two
things number one again eating wheat
butter and oats and then also eating
buckwheat people would eat buckwheat as
pancakes they'd eat buckwheat as noodles
they would eat buckwheat as kind of a
porridge okay and
um
even had buckwheat bread and stuff like
that and buckwheat has a substance in it
I'll call okay called Faygo pieia okay
or pyramid should not pyria pyrene fago
pyrene and it it actually causes
terrible terrible sensitivity of your
skin you get all red and scaly and
everything and you get a disease very
common called lupus
erythematosis lupus is caused by eating
buckwheat okay but it also destroys your
liver your intestines your brain all
that kind of stuff and it's a mess well
if you're eating buckwheat for breakfast
and snacks and you're eating gluten with
every meal we'd run around oats with
every meal you're you're in trouble and
I've been looking at in Asia and there's
certain areas of Asia where they eat a
lot of Wheat and a lot of Buckwheat and
they have Lupus at very high rates the
parts of Asia whether it's Japan or
China or Korea that live on rice and
potatoes
they don't have lupus
okay they don't have all these problems
they don't have
um psoriasis they don't have Alzheimer's
disease they don't have Parkinson's
because they're eating eggs or they're
getting their cholesterol to maintain
their brain their spinal cord and all
that kind of stuff they're not getting
Ms but once they start eating buckwheat
and wheat they can't absorb it even if
they're eating it and so that's that's
the problem and so this is why we have a
problem now and of course again I came
up with the title Dead Doctors Don't Lie
for for my first major book my first
major book Dead Doctors Don't Lie
because I was handing out obituaries of
doctors at all my meetings and this
doctor said why are you doing that
that's that's really wrong it's because
only Dead Doctors Don't Lie and that's
where I got the title for the book
and um I'm going to turn my phone off
here there's too many people trying to
get a hold of me I'll turn that off
killer man Dr Wallach
okay now my phone's off you won't hear
any more zooms and beams and all that
kind of stuff but anyway that's sort of
the background here
um simple stuff and you know I'm seeing
now families or they have three boys
okay 12 uh seven and three
they have all the equipment between
their legs as a boy you know they have
all the male parts
but their chromosomes or XX
okay this is this is a gender problem
this is going on in America right now
this is not a choice this is happening
because
um people are just eating well quote
unquote not taking vitamins and minerals
so the body doesn't have what it needs
to perform correctly and this is why
we're having all these problems okay so
with that I think it sort of lays the
groundwork to answer some questions
um of course
my thesis from those 20 000 autopsies I
did
um on that
um
the big process
um it's in the Smithsonian Institute is
a National Treasure and it sells for
twenty five thousand dollars
each okay and so we came out with a
summary of that
epigenetics the death of the genetic 3
disease transmission these sell for 25
bucks everybody should get this
okay this is the equivalent to my thesis
which is in the Smithsonian Institute
sells for 25 000 bucks each these sell
for 25 bucks each okay every family
should have this
every family should have this one okay
and then more recently every family
should have this one okay there's 37
different diseases you get from
osteoporosis of the skull
there's 37 different diseases you get
from osteoporosis skull we have squeezed
and the skull squeezes the cranial nerve
number one you get the loss of the sense
of smell your cranial or your cranium
when you get osteoporosis to squeezes uh
cranial nerve number two you get optic
nerve after pain absolutely go blind
um then cranial nerve matrices your
pupil cannot respond to life
please get double vision and let's see
here palsy a trigel nerve number five
gives squeezed you get trigeminal
religion terrible pain in the face and
seeking around your eyes
cranial nerve number six gets squeezed
you get double vision and strabismus
criminal nerve number seven gets
squeezed you get Bells Paws in your face
droops tinnitus and deafness occurs when
you get uh cranial nerve number eight
being squeezed get dizziness vertigo uh
cranial nerve number eight criminal
nerve number nine gets squeezed get loss
of gag reflex swallowing and your voice
changes prayer number ten gets squeezed
get gastroparesis it's a very serious
pain of your belly and stomach and so
forth
um and you get afib atrial fibrillation
and your doctor thinks you have a heart
problem the atrial fibrillation is your
skull squeezing cranial nerve number 10
it's actually how she approaches to the
skull it's not a heart problem don't let
them do an ablation treatment that has a
highest rate of deaths of any medical
treatment real nerve number 11 loss of
the trapezius singing Can't raise your
arms above your head and you do that
cranial nerve number 12 atrophy of the
tongue speech gag reflex and so if you
have
now the squeezing of cranial nerve
number 12 and 9 you can't communicate
then the spinal cord there's 17
different diseases you get when you have
the skull squeezing the spinal cord the
skull squeezes the spinal cord the
spinal cord is made in the brain comes
out of the back of the skull when it
squeezes the spinal cord you have all
these different diseases going on the
doctors want to give you a double hip
replacement double knee replacement they
will do they'll amputate your leg and
give you artificial legs and Limbs and
all that kind of stuff so cut your arm
off and give you artificial limbs when
you have honestly approaches to the
skull and so I'm alerting people to this
so you can make
um educated
decisions so a doctor said I need to cut
your leg off give me a try for 90 days
before you let them cut your leg off
give me 90 days before you let them do
an ablation treatment on you because you
have atrial fibrillation give me 90 days
okay
um when you have optic nerve atrophy and
you know
you want to be doing or the doctors want
to be doing
um nerve surgeries and all this kind of
stuff on your eye no give me 90 days
first before you start doing those kind
of things and we will eliminate most of
the terrible terrible terrible buy uh
products or side effects of all those
terrible Medical Treatments unnecessary
back over to you Pharmacy absolutely
right unnecessary I mean folks I want
you to think about this you know we've
all seen pictures of what a spinal cord
looks like it's basically these little
discs stacked one on top of the other
and in between the little this rubbery
substance which is the cushion that
cushions the discs well in where that
rubbery substance is is where your
nerves come out you know they can't come
out to the Bone they come out through
the the gaps in between so as that
rubbery substance starts deteriorating
and you start uh having uh bone or not
bone loss but uh loss of that it starts
pinching those nerves and depending on
where the most of that uh substance has
disappeared from is where you're going
to have the symptoms so if it's in your
neck that that's degenerative of the
most then you're going to have those
symptoms that Dr I just mentioned right
Dr Roch
that's correct you got it exactly right
so if it's in and if it's in your lower
back you're going to have symptoms down
your leg so it just depends on which
nerve is getting pinched there and that
that's the whole thing here that's why I
want to tell you a story about somebody
I've I've came across in the retail
store the other day uh this ladies in
her 30s she's been having issues that
the doctors can't explain uh but at
certain points for no reason whatsoever
her heart just goes nuts you know it it
raises it slows down it goes up
her heart goes nuts it races it slows
down it fluctuates all over the place
but it's only a certain points so they
they had to wear a heart monitor to try
to figure out what's going on and
they've been working dealing with this
for weeks now trying to figure out why
this 30 year old woman is having these
heart issues but doesn't have high blood
pressure
I'm sorry
they need to be working up here
oh yeah so you know I'm sitting here I'm
listening to our story you know she's
going off for about 20 minutes
describing everything she's been through
and all the tests she's had and all that
and finally I said do you have any back
issues
he goes well yeah
I said well here's what I want you to do
every time your heart starts having one
of these episodes
note what position you were in
for your body
because I guarantee you what's happening
is your body's getting into a certain
position and it's pinching that nerve
that's leading to the heart that
regulates the heart rate of the heart
and that's what's causing your heart to
go nuts
and no doctor has ever asked that not a
single doctor not a single doctor has
looked at her spinal cord to figure out
there's an issue there
well doctors have never heard of this
pharmacist case I'm the first one to
connect everything I'm the first one to
connect
it sounds too close to chiropracty and
they think what Chiropractic is a
quackery science so they completely
ignore
the back is being an issue
because they don't want to be accused of
supporting Chiropractic to release the
pressure on the nerves you could get rid
of symptoms but it'll graduate exactly
but you have to add the nutrition
they're so protective of their space
that they don't even want to consider
that because then that supports the
theories that chiropractors have of
relieving the the joint pain but Dr
Wallach you know as this cassette tape
taught me decades ago Dr Watt takes this
approach that a veterinarian it takes
you know we can't afford to to put
health insurance on the animals the food
would just cost astronomical if we had
health insurance I mean heck my health
insurance now I've got a six thousand
dollar deductible and I'm paying more
for my health insurance than I did 10
years ago so you know you can't you
can't treat animals with modern medicine
you can't have a chiropractor go out
there and manipulate the spinal cord of
the uh of the cow you know you just
can't do that so veterinarians have had
to take them
I'm gonna jump in here yeah because when
I became when I became an Asia Valley
doctor I started going to human meetings
and stuff and introducing myself and
saying come to me if you have a problem
I my my sort of
message was now remember I'm going to
treat you like a dog but you're going to
get better
that was my message I'm going to treat
you like a dog but you're going to get
better and they would all laugh and slap
their knee and all that kind of stuff
but I'm telling the truth when I had
Tourette Syndrome 20 doctors couldn't
figure out what my problem was over a
period of five years 20 doctors and
these were very very high-end University
pediatricians university psychiatrists
and all this kind of stuff had Tourette
syndrome
and when I when they're going to put me
in an institution for life I didn't want
to go there so I made the decision uh my
mom and dad are packing up my clothes on
a Friday night I'm sitting on the end of
the bed they're going to take me to this
institution on Monday I'm thinking well
why is it the animals on the farm don't
have the same problem I have and say
Well they're totally eating differently
than me so the next morning on Saturday
morning
I threw the Cheerios and the Wheaties
out to the chickens and I got just a
whole bunch of different pellets and and
Alfalfa pills that had vitamins and
minerals added to them put them in my
cereal bowl added milk to them I ate
them I did it again on Saturday morning
I did it again on Sunday morning I did
it on Monday Morning by Monday afternoon
by three o'clock I was cured of all my
diseases I had for six years and 20
doctors couldn't have figured out simply
because I started taking vitamins
minerals when I was nine years old I
knew the doctors were severely deficient
in knowledge in these things and that's
when I started learning got the Merc
manual which we had on the farm instead
of reading on nutritional deficiencies
and stuff like that and it's one of
those things where it just all made
sense to me it all came
to pass that I was correct when I was
nine years old and 20 medical doctors
couldn't figure it out
I want to make a great suggestion to
folks I mean this cassette tape changed
my life
I want to make a suggestion to folks
that if you've got family members that
have uh you know medical conditions are
are complaints that they're always
complaining about you know their their
big toe always hurts you know whatever
the complaint is I suggest you go out
and you buy this set here the truth
about nutrition this is a modern version
of the Dead Doctors Don't Lie I mean
it's it's very slick slick sleekly done
that's the word I'm trying to find here
it's the the DVD in the video is done
very high quality and it's something I
think appealed to people in this Modern
Age
um I think it'll appeal to them a lot
more than even the original Dead Doctors
Don't Laugh so I encourage everybody to
go the original dead doctor's online is
in nine languages so if you want to give
it to somebody I'm sure that's one of
those nine languages you know put your
phone number on it and and give out a
couple of them
so y'all share this DVD I mean
Thanksgiving get this DVD out show your
family this DVD I don't see this but uh
you can find that on drjwilex.com it's
called that Doctors Don't Lie and the
truth about nutrition and folks let's
let's just back up here uh you know Dr
White said at the very beginning that
you know minerals uh in our food aren't
the same as they used to be and I just
heard a I just came across an article
and I think it was uh The Weather
Channel to put it out but they were
trying you're gonna find this hilarious
Dr Wallach they were trying to that they
said that the nutritional value of food
has been going down now for decades
proof that part of the story is the
truth the nutritional value of food has
been going down now for decades we've
known that since
1936-37 with the Senate issued yeah when
the Senate issued that document
well here's what they said was causing
it okay now some of you out there you've
got you've had a little biology
background and you understand that this
is a total lie but they're counting on
the masses of population that have no
idea they said the global warming the
excess carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
was causing this mineral and vitamin
content of the food to go down
folks plants use carbon dioxide like we
use oxygen if there's no carbon dioxide
plants die like if we have no oxygen we
die
in fact because of this so-called
increase in carbon dioxide we're finding
areas where the rainforests and so forth
are thickening
you know areas where we're not touching
it they're thriving it's because the
excess carbon dioxide is making these
plants do their job to create oxygen
they breathe in carbon dioxide they
breathe out oxygen we breathe in oxygen
we breathe out carbon dioxide so this
whole thing saying that the excess
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere is
causing these plants that we're eating
these fruits and vegetables that we're
eating to have less nutrition is Bullock
science
and they know that the vast majority of
people out there have no idea that a
plant breeds carbon dioxide so carbon
dioxide does not hurt the plant and its
ability to produce uh you know the
vitamins that a plant produces the vital
nutrients that it produces the thing
that's causing the problem is what Dr
Ross alluded to in the very beginning we
haven't changed our firing practices
whatsoever over the decades the farm
soils are continuously being more and
more depleted of the nutrients if the
mineral is not in the soil then that
mineral is not in the plant so any
animal that eats that plant is then
minimally deficient as well so our food
source the minerals the plants as well
as the animals that we eat for food both
are lacking the nutrients that they had
a hundred years ago they're both lacking
the nutrients that they had when Jesus
walked the Earth it's been steadily
going down because we do not supplement
the Farm soil with the minerals and
that's why I am now on a new crusade to
try to get I don't you know all these
things that Dr White talks about you
know the the bonus joint program and all
that none of that's going to do any good
if you can't convince the people that
they need something
start them off with the minerals
okay if you've got a stubborn person
that doesn't want to listen to you start
them out with the minerals tell them to
take it for 30 days and then uh report
back to you how they feel in fact have
them do the health evaluation before
they start the minerals get them on the
minerals you can get it lots of
different ways it comes in these little
mineral sticks now which is very
convenient you just dump it in your
bottle of water you can get the original
Cherry mens and strawberry kiwi men's
and just plain minerals you can get the
mineral capsules there's lots of ways to
get them so get have them take the
health evaluation get them on their
minerals and then 30 days later have
them take the health evaluation again
let's see what happens and I guarantee
you that
I don't care if they've got gluten
problems or what they got just getting
the extra minerals there
into their diet every day they're going
to see some improvement and then they
might be a little more willing to listen
to you that you have the answer for
their their uh other problems that
they're suffering from
right Dr Light that's correct
that's correct it's one of those things
to
um
understand that we cannot manufacture
for the most part we do have the ability
to manufacture a little bit of vitamin C
out of our adrenal glands but that's
about it it's minimal not enough really
under these days of stress but we don't
have any capacity to manufacture
minerals we do require problems in the
environment and this is very dramatic
very dramatic and so farmers know that I
mean they can't afford to have a
veterinarian out to the farm every day
to treat the cows in them and the sheep
and and the pigs and and llamas and
wombats and chickens and turkeys and
ducks and bees and so forth
um otherwise you'd have to pay
um you know fifty dollars for a steak
it's kind of getting there right now I
think
um T-bone steaks uh right now are
running about 18 a pound
just imagine what they would be
you know
you know folks go to Tractor Supply
there's no Tractor Supply in your area
go to Tractor Supply and ask them to
show you the the mineral blocks that
they give animals and those blocks are
not just salt they actually say minerals
on there and they actually list the
minerals that are in those blocks and
there's not a veterinarian out in that
field telling that cow you can only have
three licks on that mineral block
there's not a veterinarian out there
telling the thoroughbred horse that's
worth a million dollars that you only
get three licks on that mineral block
the animal knows the body knows it
craves the minerals it licks that block
until it gets the minerals that it needs
and that's what's going on with us a
potato chip company came out with a
potato chip and their slogan was I bet
you can only can't only eat just one
you know why they said that because they
knew you are mentally deficient they put
salt on that potato chip to sulfur
mineral your body's craving minerals
you're going to eat a bunch of those
chips you're not going to solve your
minerals Cravings because all you're
getting is salt
but you're going to eat a bunch of those
chips and they knew it and they knew
they would sell millions and millions
and millions of dollars of those potato
chips with that slogan I bet you can't
eat just one
now it's very smart in their part
because sodium chloride is required by
your stomach to make hydrochloric acid
your stomach acid okay and so when a
doctor says oh don't use salt because of
the cause of having pressure that doctor
should have his license taken away and
it should be put in jail for three
lifetimes
you can tell I'm passionate about this
doctor like after seeing all these sick
people uh you know going to all these
different uh locations and yeah I'm
talking to the customers to dead people
and so
they're all dying from nutritional
deficiencies
you know and and me just seeing it in my
own practice now uh how much sicker this
uh the world has gotten we're the
richest Planet uh which which is country
in the world
and we're sick
we're what we're not the best in the
best health of all the countries in the
world there's lots of countries that are
more healthy than us
it's because we for health care then all
the countries in the world put together
mine yet we're the sickest we our life
expectancy doesn't meet that of most of
the other large countries
it doesn't meet what what it should be
based on our financial
output in health care and it all comes
back to nutrition and the doctors they
don't look at the root cause they look
at what they specialize in I specialize
in diabetes I'm going to look at the
pancreas that's all I'm going to look at
what's the pancreas doing they're not
looking at well why can the body not
absorb that Sugar why is it the body
can't handle it you know are you
deficient of strontium and in chromium
and the other layer Earth minerals that
are required for the body to do that
minerals are the
that really
we don't actually other than calcium and
some things like that most of the
minerals all they do in our body is
draft chemical reactions so the body can
do what it's supposed to do so you know
it takes a difference you're trying to
say they're not structural like calcium
is
right right so they're they're there to
be used for other processes in the body
to work for your hormones to work and Dr
Rock has mentioned a minute ago you know
we our bodies make different vitamins we
make vitamin D
but you know what it takes to make
vitamin D the the vitamin D's in our
body the active form of vitamin D is
called choli calciferol you know what it
takes to make colic calciferol it takes
cholesterol and it takes sunshine oh my
gosh you better not go out in the sun
you better cover your your body in zinc
oxide so you don't get any sun
ultraviolet rays and even worse don't
eat any eggs guys and take the statins
like we got to get that cholesterol down
to almost zero you know that cholesterol
is going to kill you if you eat quote
healthily unquote and eat buckwheat
because buckwheat has a
pyriam in it guess what
you're not going to be able to utilize
your nutrients okay because it kills
your body's ability
to do that and those buckwheats
buckwheats in the same category as wheat
by the round oats they're killer grains
don't take them
yeah so there's just so many things
that's wrong right now and over the next
few weeks we're going to talk more and
more about these things uh if you go
back on our past shows you can see where
we've talked about it but I do have a
new passion now after seeing a house
sick Society has really gotten and uh
yeah I'm on a new Mission now and we got
that CD set coming out soon I know that
the Publishers right now they're working
on the final versions of it I think
they're going to be sending the final
versions of Dr Wallach for him to review
uh and the artwork is the last thing to
be done as soon as they give me the
dimensions that I need for the artwork
so that's going to be out soon get this
truth about nutrition set comes with the
CD it comes with the DVD and it comes
with the book this is basically the
Dead Doctors Don't Lie of the 21st
century so I highly encourage you to get
that and uh drjwalek.com I don't make a
penny off the recommendation there I'm
not selling these books I don't sell any
Dr wallach's books uh all the proceeds
from the film Dr wallach's books and CDs
and DVDs go to Dr we like and I
encourage you yeah you can find some of
this stuff on Amazon but I encourage you
to go straight to Dr White's website d r
j wallick.com because why in the world
do you want to give Jeff Bezos part of
Dr wike's profits let's support Dr White
completely on this the prices are the
same whether you go to Amazon or you go
to Dr White's store so let's support Dr
Wallach let's not support Jeff Bezos on
that one folks let's give all the
proceeds to Dr Wallach shop directly
with him let's get into some questions
I've been ranting long enough and Dr
White well I'm sure there's some
questions because I've had lots of
people wonder when we're coming back
okay well thank you for the message for
Mrs Keith and let's go to callers
absolutely
all right if we have any Bobby Knight go
ahead unmute yourself
hello and thank you our Pharmacy Keith
and welcome back we really missed you we
really missed you a lot and Dr Walla I
have a question for you Dr Wallace well
what are the best ways to take
um to help these thought packs or
whatever you need per body weight what's
the best best ways to take it and what
times to take it with Dr wallet okay the
Healthy Start pack is our basic program
it has the 90 essential nutrients in it
16 minerals six zero minerals 16
vitamins 12 amps to Three fatty acids
and I like to take one Healthy Start
pack for 100 pounds of body weight so if
you weigh 110 pounds or 90 pounds or 80
pounds you take one healthy brain excuse
me you have one Healthy Start pack one
Healthy Start pack per month divide it
in half take a half of those serving at
breakfast and have those during dinner
time if you weigh 130 40 50 pounds or
more I would take the healthy brain in
hard pack or if you have like 10
different diseases you got to have a
pressure you got diabetes you got
arthritis you got dental problems uh you
have all kinds of bowel problems and so
forth I I would go oh
um and then you're on dialysis I would
go with the healthy brain and heart pack
which has 215 nutrients in it okay the
core is still the 90 essential nutrients
that's what I take I only weigh 142
pounds and I take two healthy branded
heart packs for per month take a full
dose twice a day and then for everything
from your heart valves which are
connective tissue
um and your cartilage ligaments and
tendons the skin and so on you want to
take two bottles a month of the MSM so
you can take three of breakfast lunch
for dinner time that's the raw materials
to rebuild cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue then you also want to
take
um two canisters a month of the collagen
peptides which is collagen from fish
poultry sheep and beef I take a scoop of
that at breakfast a scoop it at dinner
time they're going to need two canisters
it'll be like 10 days short if you don't
take two canisters a month and then you
also want to take the Beyond osteofx and
um you know the
the
um healthy brain and heart pack uh it
has the
um
as I say it has the Beyond tiny
Tangerine in it okay
it's our big big multiple and then of
course the um Beyond Osteo FX okay comes
also in a powder easy to put in your
drink and then the big one when it comes
to connective tissue and joints and
heart valves halogen peptides okay scuba
this twice a day and these are things we
used to have Grandma used to make bone
broth
okay
this is bone broth
okay this is bone broth but instead of
having bone broth from just say cattle
this has bone broth from fish poultry
sheep and cattle all right and so this
is the next generation of Grandma's bone
broth so if you're old enough to
remember Grandma's bone broth oh yeah I
just don't have the time to make it well
we've already pre-made it for you and
that's where I got the idea for making
the collagen peptides is Grandma's bone
broth I had it every morning and every
night and again
um you know we we didn't have any
college education no family had any
college education it was all just
Grandma telling us what to do because
um we came from the Ukraine and they're
very famous right now we came from
Ukraine and she brought all these very
various things that they used to do in
the Ukraine to stay healthy To America
with her when they came
okay back over to you
yeah one of the things as a pharmacist
too that really gets me excited uh
product wise uh actually two products
that I besides the minerals is the Tangy
Tangerine powder I I guarantee you you
will not find a more complete uh at
least I haven't yet uh
mineral supplement vitamin and mineral
supplement in this I mean it's got all
the 90 essential nutrients in it it's
got vital Pro uh
uh what's the word I'm looking for
Doctor uh it's got all the final new
Final nutrients from multiple species of
uh plants in this uh it's got things in
there for your Bone and Joints uh that
uh most likely you're not going to find
another 15 plants have been extracted to
get the nutrients to put in there 115
different plant species
and the thing is that through this
pandemic and through all the problems
that the pandemic has brought as far as
supply chain issues
they've not changed the formula on this
if there was ingredients they couldn't
get
they didn't make it
so that that did cause a back order on
some of these products but that's
because the quality they're they're so
passionate about the quality on this uh
Dr White's son Steve that uh if he can't
get the ingredients uh most companies
would just leave that particular
ingredient out to get the product out
there to make the cells if he couldn't
get what what was supposed to be in a
product he put it on back order until he
could get those ingredients in there and
that's another part of the Integrity of
this company that I that I enjoy again
as a pharmacist this is extremely
bioavailable it's made it's freeze-dried
so it goes back into liquid very easily
and because it's made from the plant
derived colloidal minerals it's very
highly bioavailable bioavailable means
it's available to your body for your
body to use and the other thing that I
pair with that all the time now is the
collagen is actually what I just
mentioned because we're all suffering
from Bone and Joint issues and not only
does it have the five main types of
collagen that are recommended now it
also has the fervic minerals in it so
it's another source of some minerals for
you and some digestive enzymes so your
body can utilize the collagen
appropriately so it's it's not single
and gradient products it's all things
that are designed to work together all
right Sherry you have a question
I I do and I I agree with my brother
Bobby Knight it's so good to see you
guys back on the calls again
um question when a person has the um a
really bad sugar Cravings in the morning
at night I I think that's Pica correct
yeah that could be a variation of Pica
you could be craving salt you could be
craving sugar you could be craving your
favorite candy you could be craving a
soft drink any craving is called Pica
and this is due to mineral deficiencies
and a lot of times sugar Cravings is is
even more specific to uh deficiencies of
your Omega fatty acids
is when
because our body Associates ice cream
and things like that because there's
fats in them so we mistake that maybe
we're craving sugar when we might
actually be craving the fat that's in in
the product so you know you got to
really look here just because somebody
says they're craving sugar you got to
find out exactly what the sugar is
they're craving is it ice cream
specifically are they created milkshakes
you know may not be the sugar that
they're craving it might be the fat
the doctors tell us stay away from the
fat it's bad for us got to stay away
from the fat
that it's candy they eat a lot of
chocolate they eat cookies they eat
sugar in the morning cakes but very
highly saving high quality chocolate
products that are very low in sugar
um some of them we just put
um actually spices in there that are
sweet that we don't put sugar in there
and so we have some great chocolate if
you're into chocolate and you don't want
the sugar we have sugar-free chocolate
products
okay and so someone told me a long time
ago if you're craving the sugar like
that take a swig of uh the Cherry mints
yeah you have a craving yeah take a shot
because it's not gonna hurt you of
course we have two we have the salt the
seasoned salt from Australia so sea salt
from Australia because right now we're
back ordered on the Himalayan salt so we
have the season in South from Australia
it's a sea salt from Australia that we
add all kinds of um herbs and things to
it to get more minerals and things in
there
Dr Wally have a question for you
um
who is Bobby okay go ahead yeah Dr
Wallach if you were building the
youngevity business to help someone get
off to a a start to work towards getting
their products for free and everything
what would you recommend Dr Wallace from
scratch if he was uh to teach someone to
build their business and what ages can
they start it okay well basically I
would start with your family and your
workmates and your church mates people
you're in contact with on a regular
basis
and you want to give them a sample okay
so you have to become an associate AKA a
distributor yourself
and then as you do that you want to give
everybody a free sample and it could be
just three or four tablets in a little
one of those little plastic bags with a
Ziploc top and of course that's tax
deductible because you're giving away as
a sample to grow your business
you know also as far as Keith pointed
out we have the book and the CD and the
DVD called the truth about nutrition if
people have questions you say well I'll
loan you the set okay you have to give
it to them okay you will loan you this
set because it'll teach you why you need
to take these things and if they have
osteoporosis of the skull with any one
of those or any mixture of those 37
different diseases we have the book and
the CD it's on your head okay and so
there's a lot of information that people
can take and they can listen to other
driving they can listen to other
families uh we have the book epigenetics
we have the book dead in the lime we
have the book Hell's Kitchen which
Hell's Kitchen I like because it goes
through the transition from coal and
what is fuel to electricity and what
happened to our health when we made that
transition from wood and coal as fuel
putting the wood ashes and coal ashes in
our Gardens putting the wood ash Lashes
in our food suddenly now when we have
electricity oh we don't have those
byproducts anymore more to put in our
foods and doctors saying don't waste
your time and money on on buying
vitamins and meals just eat well okay so
you're getting hit from both sides uh
now because of the change in the source
of fuels
and one other tool I would recommend if
you are serious about building the
business is the uh
website from The Institute of holistic
health uh let me share my screen here so
you can see what I'm talking about
as you can see my version of it by going
to campaign fornutrition.com but this
website has links on here hopefully you
guys can see it two Dead Doctors Don't
Lie it has links on here to Dr Lodge the
rest of the story I has a link to their
call to a video called The Audacity Of
Health by Dr log so it's an excellent
tool in this Modern Age where you can
share this with you if there's a monthly
membership fee to it but uh it has all
that it even has a link to your back
office uh your store so people can order
products directly from you from that
page so that's a nice little tool that I
use that I would recommend people take a
look at as well
yeah and that tells can you still hear
me yeah okay yeah I hear you five yeah
the Dr Joel Wallach story that goes into
the beginning of the story where I got
fired for finding and discovering the
cause for mentioning cure for the birthy
effect sitting ambrosis ought to be a
genetic disease that was my first
mistake when I found the cause
prevention cure for Cystic Fibrosis they
fired me from the European primate
Center and over all these years they've
never sent me a letter saying you know
we're really sorry we did that 30 years
ago but they've never done that but um
they really really were very naughty
they fired me my wife had just died it
had four little kids and they didn't
care they just fired me because
um when I handed them my paper that I
was going to have published because he
had to hand them the paper for them to
review and they just summarily fired me
because I said you have got to be
smoking too much pot wallet because
um everybody knows the city of roses is
the classic example of a genetic
um birth defect in humans no it was a
simple nutritional deficiency
okay
there you go that's the rest of the
story
all right do we have any other questions
we got just a few minutes left
yes yeah real quick go ahead Bobby
so the two that you have uh the holistic
help that's good to share with people as
well as done
the nutritional um books CD and that's
one of the best ways of doing it just
saying yeah educator Michelle and alone
you're the CD and book set I'm gonna
loan it to you if you want to buy it
here's the price but I'm going to loan
it to you I want it back in two weeks
because I have other people I want to
loan it to and so in the beginning you
loan it to them and say if you want to
buy it here's the price you can share it
with your family but you've got two
weeks because I want it back I'll be
banging on your door to get my CD and my
book back
and you can answer I'll answer any
questions for you and um you know leave
them your card you know with a sample
maybe of um something like one of those
sticks of the rebound or sports drink it
comes in sticks 36 in a box or it comes
36 servings in the canister
it also we have cans of rebounds but the
cans I like to pop them open the night
before I drink them put them in the
refrigerator so the off gas the
carbonation at night so they're flat in
the morning all the bubbly's gone but
these are are the same formula it's just
that the powder and the sticks don't
have the carbonation in it like the cans
do so the cans I have to do the extra
thing apart from the top won't have the
carbon carbonation in them the next
morning
and they're self-shareable the sticks
and this is the middle of six this is
basically the Cherry mens that have been
I'm assuming the same process uh
freeze-dried down into the powder just
Scotch taped that to your business card
and and okay
so this is all right
you are on the radio twice a day every
single day uh tell folks how they can
reach By Radio
okay Monday through Friday has been
going on for 32 years and now
um let's see here first one is noon
Pacific Time noon to 1 Pacific time uh
Dead Doctors Don't Lie the telephone
number is toll-free triple eight eight
eight eight three seven nine two five
five two that's Triple Eight three seven
nine two five five two and then from one
to two Monday through Friday it's let's
play doctor okay and that number is
877-912 play
877-912-7529 and uh it's one of those
things where I've been doing this like
almost forever 32 years
and
we do have all these various
um like I say I think I have over 100
CDs I have over 50 DVDs and there's
bound to be one you might want to hear
but um
again I think
um performance is Keith did a good thing
when he went to uh we we have the book
and the CD and the DVD of the truth
about nutrition don't forget the CD Dead
Doctors Don't Lie it's in uh
1919 or nine nine excuse me nine
languages nine languages and
um the book is in two languages we sell
so many of the Spanish people I have one
distributor who buys one case of the
Spanish dead dungeon live books and one
case of the English books every week he
just drives up and buys a case of each
language every week and he's growing
such a huge huge huge business helping
thousands of people every month with
their health problems
absolutely and folks you can get the
books at drjwalek.com I've got that on
the screen right now
drjwalich.com and one more time on the
radio uh that uh for those of us on the
East Coast at three to four pm eastern
time three to four p.m
888-379-2552 and you can listen to The
Archives of that radio show by going to
radio dot give Doc 90days.com and I have
that on the screen as well right now
radio dot give Doc 90days.com and
finally let's play doctor is weekdays
from 4 to 5 p.m Eastern Time
877-912-7529-877-912-7529 Dr Mark I want
to thank you very much for uh doing this
it's something that again I am
passionate about I've renewed my passion
by seeing how sick people have been and
uh you know we're gonna do this every
week same time now
Mr Keith we cannot thank you enough for
your insights your passion to help
people we respect you and love you for
it God bless you and we'll look forward
to next week
absolutely and folks I've got a free
gift for you just for uh watching I've
no I've said this before in the past but
if you go over to uh hang on let me
share the screen again
there you go if you go over to the
website d d
lvideo.com that stands for Dead Doctors
Don't Laugh d d lvideo.com you can watch
the uh 2014 version of Dead Doctors
Don't Lie called someone should go to
jail that's a video there of that you
can share it with other people we don't
ask for any information when you go to
that website it doesn't ask people to
give their their email or phone number
or anything it's free for everybody to
use and there's also a document there
that you can download and print out uh
called why so many young athletes die
again that's uh
dddlvideo.com and uh thank you very much
for sharing this information and if you
want to find out more about the products
and more about Dr Wallach and I
encourage you to reach out to the person
that shared this with you to share this
program with you and ask them to get the
information to you if you you found this
on your own through Facebook or YouTube
or wherever you might have found it a
podcast then go to
campaign4nutrition.com you can learn
everything you want to learn there about
Dr wallyk if you want to learn more
about me go to ask pharmacist keith.com
and there's information there about me
and my background so thanks again folks
for joining us I'm going to have to jump
off here my new schedule puts me going
to work here in about an hour so need to
get ready for that again thank you Dr
walek appreciate it so much this is
something that I look forward to every
week and I have missed it tremendously
the last two months so thank you God
bless thank you thank you thank you for
all you do God bless everybody
bye-bye have a great day thank you
thanks for tuning in to the health and
wellness hour with Dr Joel Wallach and
pharmacist Keith Abel if you found value
in this episode be sure to like and
share also to be notified when the next
episode is posted click on the Subscribe
button then hit that little bell symbol
if you have any questions or comments
for pharmacist Keith or Dr Wallach you
may send a private email to ask
pharmacist Keith at live.com or by
visiting the Facebook page give doc 90
days to Better Health wellness and
Longevity to hear more from Dr rollick
he has two nationally syndicated radio
programs daily Dead Doctors Don't Lie
and let's play doctor check your local
radio listings for details also check
out the archives of his past shows at
Radio dot give doc 90days.com one last
thing if you'd like to join Dr White's
crusade to share his message with others
contact pharmacist Keith and he'll teach
you how to share the message and create
some extra income at the same time
contact pharmacist Keith through his
email address Keith prosperityrx.com
or call or text at
502-212-2929 remember Keith is still a
practicing pharmacist and can't always
pick up the phone right away so leave
your name number and best time to call
and he'll return your call as soon as
possible thanks again for tuning in
[Music]